我们女人啊，
做什么事儿先定定心神，
我最想要的东西是什么？
别就是乱七八糟的出招数，
什么华山剑，
九阴白骨爪，
什么飞毛腿，
就别乱七八糟的出这些招数，
你先定定心神，
你最想要的东西是什么？
我现在是38岁，
有一个女儿是10岁，
我们夫妻是有一套房子是婚后买的，
现在价值大概130万，
他有一个婚前的房子卖了大概90万，
我们又凑了一点买的，
这个90万里面有二三十万是他父母提供的，
婚后再还房贷，
后来卖掉了，
有一辆车，
反正不值什么钱。
还有一套房子是写的我们的名字，
其实是他哥哥出资我们贷使的，
大概也是100多万，
这套房子是他哥哥付的首付，
我们还贷款，
还贷款其实也是我们之前欠他哥哥的钱，
等于说这套房子都是他哥哥才出钱，
还贷款的过程中就没还几年，
我老公借了我父母二十几万，
把贷款还清了，
借你父母这二十几万也相当于你们还了哥哥的钱，
是这意思不，
因为他哥哥等于说名下房子比较多嘛，
当时就是用我们的名字买的房子，
他剩的贷款就相当于我们把之前欠他的钱给还了，
我刚问的意思就是嘛，
说你的父母出的这20万。
把这个哥哥的实际拥有的这套房子的贷款给还完了，
相当于这20万，
其实也是还了哥哥的债了，
是这个意思啊啊对对对，
其实是还有一部分债权是我最近才发现的，
通过他跟他哥哥的聊天记录，
因为他在他哥哥公司上班，
他到意思就是他们公司可能还欠他大概100万没有给，
这个是近几天他聊天记录看到的，
那这100万是婚前的劳动所得还是婚后的劳动所得呢？
婚后我最近就我老公，
我就发现他是有在网上就喜欢跟别的女人聊一些暧昧的话嘛，
喜欢做足疗，
还问有没有特殊服务之类的，
就一个月就发现跟之前比较特别不对劲，
通过一些手段嘛，
就是看她的聊天记录啊，
什么录音之类的，
就知道她是有处，
是一个固定的一个女孩子，
应该是一个未婚的女孩子，
你发现之后跟她摊牌了吗？
没有，
现在这财产方面的话，
总共其实借了我父母大概40万，
还了7万，
还剩了三十几万，
当时其实里面有二十几万就去还房贷，
还有三十几万就没还，
我让我老公还的时候，
他都是说没钱，
因为小孩现在四年级，
上小学之后，
我是全职的，
他现在给家里生活费，
他如果挣到钱，
我估计他是剩下的钱就投到那个项目里面了，
现在公司就欠他100万，
因为他们是家族钱，
就直接生活费就没有给。
那款就一直欠着，
我之前是以为他是固定工资，
每年到年底的时候会问他一年挣多少钱，
他都不说，
我一直以为他可能还是固定工资，
我这两天看聊天记录发钱的，
我没有跟他摊谈，
我就想多收一点证据，
他哥哥的公司还欠他100万，
这个事儿你也没跟他摊牌是吧，
都没有摊牌。
债权证据的话，
好像目前没有实锤证据，
只是一个聊天记录，
聊天记录只说了个大概，
没有特别清楚，
我就是想问，
这个债权如果说要那种很官方的什么证据，
我肯定是做不到的，
只是聊天方面就双方都认可100万，
这样有没有效啊，
挺难的，
只有这么一个聊天记录，
因为很多东西啊，
公司和他之间的关系，
其实说白了就是他哥一个人说了算的事儿嘛，
他们之间又没有签什么股权激励，
又没有搞什么原始股的合同，
又没有搞什么提成的分红的这样一个规则，
书面的东西搞了咱们也搞不到，
其实就是他哥一句话的事儿，
他哥可以解释啊，
说那你今年还给公司造成损失了呢，
一扣一底的话，
你就没有100万了吗？
所以这事儿的话，
我感觉也甭惦记人家那100万，
我我不想惦记他那个100万，
我就是想把他作为筹码，
因为我是想要我们目前自己住的这套房子，
你要想要你们现在自己住的那套房子的话，
其实有一定的筹码，
为什么呢？
因为他哥哥那套房子不是登记在你们两口子名下吗？
你不配合变更登记的话，
也挺麻烦的。
对，
我跟你说的他哥那套房子也是这个意思，
一个是债权，
还有一个是登记在我们名下这套房子，
对你就说咱们公平点来讲啊，
比如说你自己挣的这100万，
公平点来讲，
我也不想说能够分你一半，
你总得给孩子留一点吧，
你给孩子留个30万也不过分吧，
再加上我爸妈也出了那么多钱去还养贷，
给你还哥哥的钱，
那你就把那个130万那套房给我呗，
其他的我都放弃呗，
我还想能不能再争取更多，
他还欠我爸妈的，
还剩33万万挺难的，
因为你130万那个房的话，
主要是人家卖了婚前的90万的房产，
就130万那套房的话，
相当于人家婚前的就占90万，
其中他爸妈出了二三十万，
那你们婚后的话，
130万当中只有40万是你们婚后的，
那划下来的话，
其实你就分到个20万，
你要想要那一套130万的房产的话，
你可能还是得算明白账了，
不然的话他也不傻，
他那个婚前卖掉那套房，
其实他父母只出了首付，
其他的都是我们婚后还贷夫妻共同财产，
他婚前那套房你们夫妻还贷还了多少钱呢？
这个我没计算过，
大概一年还多少钱，
一个月还多少钱，
每一个月2000多，
一个月2000多，
一年也就二万四，
那可能五六七年吧，
五六七年加起来也就十几万，
卖掉了90万是借钱把房贷还掉了，
卖掉借的钱又是你们两口子共同来还是吗？
实际上。
是没出什么钱，
而且这个房子的这90万可能还增值了，
当时卖的时候是不是应该增了一点吧？
我说这个话啊，
我就是让你先明白这个道理，
你俩这130万的这婚后的这个房子啊，
如果真分到你手里的话，
他肯定还是会考虑这个因素的，
第一考虑他爸妈出了二三十万的首付，
第二考虑到这个是他婚前的房产，
第三也会考虑到你们婚后之后还了一部分的贷款，
这些都会考虑进去，
还会考虑什么呢？
还会考虑对家庭的贡献，
你们共同孕育了子女，
也是有可能说比你实际付出的分的多得多，
举个例子，
这130万，
你实际付出了30万，
你也是有可能能分到五六十万的，
因为为啥你结婚时间长了十几年了呀，
孩子都10岁了呀，
而且这是登记在你们夫妻共同名下的呀，
你这个家庭有贡献呀，
你带孩子呀，
也是有可能的，
有可能报体的都有可能。
我们现在住的这个房子，
因为是属于二套房，
一直没有办房产证，
买的时候也是他一个人的名字，
会成为是我婚内夫妻共同财产的一个阻碍嘛，
不是，
只要是你婚后买的，
而且动用了你们共同的存款，
动用了你们共同去还房贷的话，
在法律定性上，
不管是在你名下还是在他名下，
不影响，
我是想跟他谈判签婚内财产协议，
你也可以试一下，
第一试一下他怕不怕被周围的人知道，
他在外面又找了个第三者，
也可以谈判，
当然更好谈。
完了之后就先去办过户，
把在他名下的这一套房子130万是吧，
把这套房子过户给你，
就我这种情况，
可能谈判的话会比诉讼，
如果谈的好，
会拿到更好的结果是吧？
是诉讼，
他那100万的劳动收入很难打回来，
但如果谈判就不一样了，
谈判了毕竟是涉及到他哥哥，
而是而他哥哥还有房产在你们的手上，
涉及到这些复杂的关系，
他也不想他的哥哥到时候为难他，
是有可能谈回来更好的结局的。
谈判的时候没有经验，
应该用什么话术能让他统一签字呢？
我感觉你这事儿的话，
可能得先把这个协议都起草好，
趁哪天比如说孩子不在家，
老人带孩子的话，
就每天就你们两口子在的时候，
你要把他的聊天记，
把他出这些记录，
一定要猜测打印出来，
甩在他面前，
一定要让他觉得你是非常决绝的，
就这事儿对你伤害太大了，
就你跟他谈的时候，
上来的方案一定是要你父母，
我要么一起啊，
就让他有这种感觉啊，
一个那种打印出来的，
打印出来他会不会有接心啊，
还是手写，
现场手写也行，
你能记得住的话，
你也能现场手写啊，
这个婚内财产协议我在那个当地的律师，
我打电话问过，
就让他们乞讨大哥也不便宜，
在网上的那种婚内财产协议靠谱吗？
专业的事儿还是交给专业的人干啊，
不然的话，
万一你写一个不靠谱的，
你等于白折腾浪。
的这样一个唯一的机会，
你可能到最后他琢磨过份儿来了，
他不害怕了，
他破罐子破摔了，
他觉得他打官司的话，
他能分到更多了，
他就没有机会了，
当天谈当时就得让他签，
而且当天谈当天签完了之后，
当天拿着所有的证件你都预约好，
当天就去办才行，
早上谈，
下午办，
下样午就去办过户之类的，
对，
那我这个房子房产证还没办，
那一次性就直接过户到我这边嘛，
那你得问一下当地的那个房管部门了，
那这事儿我就说不准了，
我想问一下我老公他的这个性格，
情商比较低嘛，
性欲比较强那种，
他就喜欢看点动作片啊什么之类的，
你如我说一点略微稍微潮流一点的词，
他可能都听不懂，
就这种性格，
这个我我如果做好准备，
让他签的话，
他签的概率大不大，
他有一点暴力那种现象，
反能在家里，
什么暴力啊，
辱骂啊，
反正都有过，
我真拿不准他的离婚协议要不要一起去签了，
我估计他是愿意离婚的，
你想离吗？
想啊，
你想离了你就准备呗，
好的，
好啊，
就这样啊，
好拜拜。
但是我跟大家说一个逻辑啊，
这个逻辑是什么呢？
我们女人啊，
做什么事先定定心神，
我最想要的东西是什么？
别就是乱七八糟的出招数，
什么华山剑，
九阴白骨爪，
什么飞毛腿，
就别乱七八糟的出这些招数，
你先定定心神，
你最想要东西是什么，
因为有的时候就算。
想要离的话，
你也要分策略是吧？
就算我想要离，
我是不是离之前我得把该是我的财产揣我兜里，
我再一步一步的实施离的方案，
对不对？
你不能上来，
又想要房子归我，
又想要离，
你要男的一般出轨的时候，
他为啥愿意妥协，
为啥愿意房子给你，
车子给你，
存款给你？
他肯定是想要求点啥的，
要么求你原谅，
要么求你别把我这丑事到处去说去，
别让我爸妈知道，
别让这同事们都知道，
要么求你别离，
他负担不起再组建一个家庭的成本，
否则的话，
他我凭啥同意多分你钱？
理解这个逻辑吗？
记得点赞关注哦。